à
irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
e
c'est la seconde partie de notre voyage
au liban avec vous jacques robert
boissier pouvez vous nous dire où nous
sommes bien nous prenons la montagne
cette fois ci pour aller vers les
sources de l'adonis vers afca que renan
estimait être un ici les plus beaux du
monde
et à votre avis c'est aussi très beau
c'est également très beau nous allons
faire un crochet en passant par bétadine
bétadine le palais de l'émir béchir qui
est situé devant ces maisons avec 3
ogives typiquement les manez juste au
dessus de ces cultures en terrasses
splendide qui sont ici très verte
toujours les cultures en terrasses de
tous les côtés en face à rots à gauche
par tout hébété et nous arrivons à bt
voici le palais
la terrasse de l'entrée du palais
quelle couleur jaunâtre un peu blond
lapierre est assez blonde
et les trois au genou
3 ogives qui sont typiques de la maison
libanaise que l'on retrouve sur beaucoup
de maisons et qui l ont désiré saman le
président chamoun venait régulièrement
travailler à un certain nombre de
week-end et ouest
le bureau il du président qu'il occupait
c'est là qu'ils travaillaient qui
donnait sur cette cour intérieure
extrêmement reposante
il ya une douceur de vivre c'est très
monaca les cyprès monacale quelle
altitude 600 m à peu près oui c'est déjà
donc un faux fraîcheur raison de la
fraîcheur et s'étendant de l'eau s'est
entourée d'arbres il ya beaucoup d'eau
les murs sont prêts travailler c'est pas
tout ça ce sont des hommes ce sont des
mosaïques
un exemple de mosaïques typique du paris
c'est un des endroits les plus reposants
de tout le pays c'est du bois peint les
plafonds sont extrêmement jolie sont
très travaillés son temps lumineux
oui vous voyez des glaces pourquoi le
lendemain c'est joli mais ça évidemment
ses attrapés rayon de la lumière au
rayon de la lumière
c'est très pur enfin très beau toujours
des brebis mais cette fois son petit
mouton et thibault mi noir et sont
noires celles ci du reste les brevets
et elle continue à dévorer l'herbe à la
sab le mans a mangé le pays petit à
petit la route typiquement libanaise des
routes sont splendides très bien très
très bien fait
espèce de brume pourquoi parce que
maintenant nous avons quitté b testing
pour aller vers africa oui la csn source
de la démission nous parliez tout à
l'heure
source de l'adonis qui sont situées à
l'endroit où adonis est réputé avoir été
mises à mort par le sanglier envoyé par
mars les sources de l'adonis sorte de
cette grotte pour former un peu plus
loin la rivière adonis qui s'appelle
maintenant le nahr ibrahim
le débit est très important mais il ne
faut pas oublier que nous sommes au
printemps c'est le moment
au printemps alors nous avons fait
encore un autre bon et nous sommes à
bécharré et sommes donc à huy c'est très
loin de relativement loin dhafra plus
exactement c'est à une centaine de
kilomètres nous sommes dans le nord 1
les voilages les attendaient depuis le
début ces fameux cèdre et nous arrivons
à l'endroit appelé justement les cèdres
qui est une station de sports d'hiver où
se trouve l'implantation des plus beaux
cèdre du liban
le cèdre dit de lamartine
guy de lamartine car en réalité il
n'aurait jamais mis les pieds au sec une
légende que vous faites nous rire c'est
tout à fait triste
il y en a à peu près une centaine ils
sont tous vieux oui dans l'ensemble
aussi de la neige selon thain et son
éternel sénat joue pas non l'été il ya
la pluie n'y en a pratiquement calé
pardon quel est le plus haut sommet à
peu près du liban ces 2000 il doit
situer autour de 2800 mètres et je ne
vous garantis par le chiffre exact
voilà l'ensemble de l'implantation des
cèdres à cet endroit autrefois parait-il
tout le mond liban était couvert par ces
armes puisque les barques des phéniciens
était en bois de seine et c'est
peut-être moins de 7 ans maintenant
les bateaux et les chèvres oui
toujours la culture 1 terrasse
un des hôtels des cèdres et tout cela
sur hivernale maintenant fait avec des
colonnes romaines
oui nous sautons maintenant par dessus
la montagne et nous apercevons dans le
fond la fameuse plaine de la bekaa la
richesse du liban c'est là où culture
toutes les cultures cette plaine étant
situé entre le mont liban d'une part et
l'anti liban d'autre part et de l'autre
côté de l'anti liban oui nous arrivons
en syrie oui sa ligne à la côte le mont
liban la bk l'anti liban et la syrie
plus exactement la république arabe unie
et ici nous sommes maintenant nous
sommes tout près de baalbeck
qui est à plusieurs centaines de mètres
d'altitude même plus me mettre plus de
1000 mhz est un tout petit peu plus de
1000 mètres autour de 11 100 m la
fameuse baalbeck qui était situé à un
carrefour de routes et où les romains
justement on construit fameuse acropole
dédié à jupiter haliopolis cette année à
toi effectivement elle vaut souvent sur
le quotidien on en rencontre dans cette
région assez souvent elles ont gardé les
moeurs antique mais on en voit de moins
en moins celle ci s'est également une
image que l'on voit maintenant assez
rarement le cimetière chrétien
de baalbeck
et quelle est la proportion est
chrétienne à baalbeck et ne doit pas
dépasser à l'heure actuelle 25 %
elle a beaucoup diminué et ceci est ce
que c'est ce qu'on appelle la fameuse
grosse pierre c'est paraît-il la plus
grosse pierre taillée du monde elle est
d'un seul bloc
c'est monolithique et c'est avec des
pierres de cette taille qu'elle a
construit le temple de baalbeck on admet
que cette pierre pèse à peu près le
poids de trois grosses la domotique
locomotive oui trois bébés
voilà les propylées l'entrée de
l'acropole et nous voici dans la
première cour de l'acropole qui a une
forme hexagonale et qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs la cour hexagone
un parent relief qui est très bien
conservé nous sautons maintenant dans
l'autre court qui édite cour de l'hôtel
voici les splendides chapelle latérale
avec les très belles colonnes
toutes les pierres que vous irez pendus
ont été jetés à terre par un grand
nombre de tremblements de terre il ya eu
fréquemment il y a eu je crois en 1759
un tremblement de terre qui a duré 27
jours et 28 nuits et c'est ce
tremblement qui a réussi à ébranler ce
point oui exactement
il ne reste plus que six colonnes
est prêt
la veille
certains en bouche il revêt sur les
quatre courtes
est ce que vous connaissez la
signification savard vient
vous apercevez l'oeuf signifie la vie
les bas reliefs de la piscine où les
prêtres faisaient leurs ablutions avant
de monter à l'hôtel non c'est l'escalier
monumental qui monte au temple
proprement dit cet escalier à faire
effet avec des énormes blocs de pierre
et c'est dans ces énormes blocs que les
marches ou était de pallier ce n'est pas
une construction en fait cet itunes une
taille dans une pierre exactement si
bien eu lieu très usés probablement par
les tremblements de terre les fameuses
colonnes de baalbeck qui sont très
belles elles sont autres
on ne se détache 6ème prix
très sociable
au plan les colonnes
mais souvent dessous non au pied des
colonies extrêmement tôt
trois pierres qui sont restés l'une sur
l'autre comme par un miracle nous
arrivons au temple qui est situé à côté
du grand temple principal de jupiter
liot politain qui est le temple de
bacchus ou temple de vénus temple de
vénus car c'est là qu'il y avait les
orgies
plafonds sont restés identiques à ceux
qu'ils étaient à l'époque primitive
on est un peu restée le gouvernement
libanais à l'heure actuelle fait un très
gros efforts pour restaurer baalbeck et
tous les ans d'ailleurs il y à un
festival
oui qui est connu dans le monde entier
et c'est extrêmement beau il s'entraîne
large c'est comment tu fais pour
construire se posent les questions m eh
bien les colonnes étaient les chutes
colonnes étaient reliés les uns aux
autres avec du plomb fondu et ont dressé
l'ensemble après londres et c'est
l'ensemble ensuite les commandes
c'est un système de palan de levier
c'est une à cologne qui s'était presque
à fondre et demie position
le mur qui a été construit par les
arabes qui en avait fait un château fort
quelques exemples encore des bas-reliefs
qui n'était pas vous reconnaissez l'oeuf
symbole de la vie toujours la rose qui
était un motif très utilisé c'est très
fouillé comme des saints aux yeux
magnifiques
c'est une des plus belles choses que
l'on fût soir à baalbeck dieu on ne sait
pas regarder la narine frémissante
un très beau chapiteau qui aussi s'était
fourré le petit temple rond dit
également de vénus qui est située à
l'extérieur des ruines et communiquent
qui communiquait par un souterrain avec
le temple de bacchus
nous avons vu tout à l'heure et
l'ensemble l'ensemble des ruines
une des plus belles choses de cet
admirable pays
merci jacques robert boissier
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé un voyage
sans passeport en compagnie de jacques
robert boissier réalisation solange
péters montage michel la touche sont
christian hatlo
jean-paul tic emploi script lucette
andrieu illustration sonore dominic
palladini